l'acte européen sur la liberté des
médias est actuellement en discussion
par le mont européen elle a été
présentée en septembre dernier par la
Commission et cet acte vise à garantir
des médias libres et aussi assurer leur
pluralité c'est quand même oui qui l'eût
cru il y a encore quelques années mais
de plus en plus de journalistes en
Europe craignent pour leur vie et leur
intégrité physique en 2021 2
journalistes ont été assassinés au
Pays-Bas et en Grèce ce futur règlement
européen visa renforcer l'indépendance
des médias face aux ingérences des
gouvernements mais ils ne devrait
également servir à lutter contre les
concentrations dans le secteur privé
concentration qui font courir un risque
pour la liberté de la presse Laurence
pharaon est député européenne il y a
bien sûr la protection des journalistes
qui est intégrée pas d'espionnage des
journalistes protection des sources
interdiction de ce qu'on appelle les
procédures Bayons c'est à dire c'est
poursuites qui sont faites sur les
journalistes pour les empêcher de parler
donc ça c'est un point qui sera coulé
dans la loi donc un point important et
qui sera établi à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne une question qui vise à
empêcher les concentrations des médias
abusifs c'est à dire dès lors qu'elles
peuvent là encore attenter à
l'indépendance qu'elles peuvent faire en
sorte que les les médias tombent aux
mains d'un pouvoir à son simple profit
donc ce point de la concentration des
médias il est très important parce que
le problème qu'on va avoir avec la
Pologne la Hongrie notamment c'est des
questions de concentration aux mains de
l'État ou d'entreprise proche du proche
du pouvoir et puis dans d'autres pays
comme le nôtre par exemple aux mains du
secteur privé parce qu'on voit aussi
c'est le secteur privé qui va détenir
une majorité des titres donc c'est des
situations très différentes et on voit
qu'on a un équilibre à trouver sur ce
texte européen notamment comment on va
arbitrer cette question de la
concentration des médias et bien en
créant dans chaque État membre
l'existence d'un régulateur donc un
comité européen pour le service des
médias c'est un peu notre
[Musique]
aujourd'hui devenu Arcom en France nous
avons une telle structure mais elle
n'existe pas au sein de chaque État
membre donc là encore ce sera un apport
mais c'est aussi des difficultés des
questions qui se posent et donc des
négociations à venir importantes avec
les différents États membres pour
premièrement créer ces organes
transnationaux de régulation et leur
donner un véritable rôle parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans le texte ils sont là
à titre consultatif mais on voudrait
qu'il puisse aller plus loin qu'ils
puissent s'auto saisir de questions qui
posent problème dans dans des
concentrations notamment Laurence Foran
député européenne